hi I am Greg Salkin and I'm going to be
reading some first tweets Greg Tolkien
unproblematic white man supports
minorities in the LGBT community super
talented but underappreciated thank you
loves puppies indeed has dimples yes I
guess I do has lips
I do indeed thankfully have lips y'all
we've decided to stand I don't know what
that means thank you for the stuff
before the compliments I appreciate that
and yes I do support minorities and the
LGBT community I could lick milk shake
off Gregg Sulkin any day well thank you
very much for that yes yes I don't know
how to react I don't know who wants to
lick milkshake off me Gregg Sulkin 's
lips are just so perfect and how he
always is licking them is just perfect I
want to suck them off his face honestly
I'm getting now self-conscious about my
lips I guess they're just natural I
don't really know I didn't know I lick
them a lot now I just lick them because
I just read that I like them and you
want to start them off my face please
don't because I need them to eat Gregg
Sulkin makes me want to cry
BC July again another lovely compliment
I do try to you know keep in shape Gregg
Sulkin in Wizards of Waverly Place is
one of the reasons I love British boys
so much well on behalf of all the
British boys out there we thank you for
your love thanks for being a Mason
Grayback fan I would let Gregg Sulkin
run me over with that car if it meant
that I could stare at him IRL for 30
seconds I don't know what IRL means I
would like I wouldn't run you over no no
I'm not running anybody over with a car
I appreciate your love that's they say
it does not make sense how hot Gregg
Sulkin is and now I'm getting a contour
my mum thanks you for being so kind
about her son
naked Gregg Sulkin stabbed me
ah boy um I'd rather not both stand
there naked or stab you kind of want
great tokens a blow out my back I'm not
sure if you mean like in the gym or in
the bedroom let's just hope it's the gym
congrates ol king just choked me already
let's keep the hand away from the throat
safety first I could open my legs to
Gregg Sulkin all day literally nothing
to say nothing to say this person says I
wonder what Gregg Sulkin is up to these
days I'd suck well let me tell you I'm
I'm an actor let me tell you about my
career got a new Marvel show coming out
December 13th on Hulu season 3 and yeah
just enjoy the show a lot of people
actually talk to me about my last name
but I've never actually heard this one
before Gregg Sulkin do you mean Gregg
suck in my [ __ ]
no actually I think when my mom named me
Gregg sake she was very aware that she
would name me Gregg Sulkin last names
just kind of sort of a platonic name by
no means did it mean that I would suck
in your [ __ ]
I want that bottom Gregg Sulkin to eat
my ass out well not sure if you know but
I'm gonna sort of like get up get out
get healthy train and so the only things
I'm eating these days pure protein like
carbs I even brought my own water jug
it's important to stay hydrated
all right thankfully the last one let me
guess probably talking about arseholes
hey Gregg Sulkin can spray cheese up my
[ __ ] and I would be super horny look
maybe it's an American thing but in
England we don't spray cheese not sure
what happens here but obviously you got
a cheese fetish
[Music]